Charlie and I met because we shared an
addiction not when any of you are
thinking tennis and we had a mutual
friend Jim Durant who was very close to
Charlie as a friend very fine tennis
player and I knew Tim and one day said
would you like to come over to Chaplin's
to play some doubles on Saturday our
given Saturday and I said if the tennis
is up to quality yes and I went over and
met with Charlie
he was very hospitable very gracious
played and then left Tim asked me up the
following week and the same thing
occurred and then in the middle of the
next week Charlie's Butler Watson who
was the butler in the butler did it
Charlie loved to torment him but that's
another story but Watson called me and
said mr. Chaplin would like for you to
come over and play some tennis with him
this would be singles on this Wednesday
afternoon and I went over and that was
the start of our playing together over a
few years about four times a week and it
was very enjoyable and after the tennis
we would go up to the Sun porch where he
used to write and he loved to have a
scotch old fashioned and I would
participate in that with him
so you see it was a good friendship it
was the last scene of the big truck
Charlie in this last scene it won't
spoil the picture Boyle he dies
but well I won't go into the details of
the scene but at a given point in this
scene he is it all happens on stage of
the theater he is removed lying dead as
prostrate the camera pulls back as he on
this portable carrier they put him on
after he's collapsed pulls back towards
the wings in the scene at the time
Buster Keaton Nigel Bruce who always
said don't call me niggle Nigel Bruce
Sidney Chaplin and myself and as the
camera pulls back and this contraption
that they've laid Charlie on is pulling
back we go back with it so that shot is
always in front of us and the cameras
holding on Charlie as it builds back
during the shot I hear what I think is
whispering and I strained my neck and
it's Buster and he is saying as we pull
back
hold still Charlie not moving his lips
and it's a whisper and he's saying
hold still Charlie don't move yeah
you're right in the center of the shot
yeah it's good hold it
right this Center you know it hold it
Yeah right listen to you right this is
it yeah Keeton directing Chaplin one of
the great moments in the history of
dhaba Jersey